is one of the craziest things to me is
that fox news is more accurate today
than all these other outlets they are
and what wait it's funny because you
know what I think happened if you look
at this is an example of use of the past
few days if you look at the Daily Show
with Jon Stewart
when James Vijay Mizuki fanned Project
Veritas released the Acorn expose yep
Jon Stewart uncritically showed the
footage he was showing the footage and
he didn't say very much at all about
project Fair toss he was like look at
what these people are saying oh man this
acorn stuff is crazy and then he said if
this guy can do this journalists where
were you I don't mean that's a huge
compliment for Veritas yes and the
audience cheered mmm and then Jon
Stewart retires and now we get current
year little Timothy you know and it's
Mantha B but I feel like Jon Stewart had
no problem being honest when someone
like James O'Keefe would get it right
but when he leaves you end up with this
formulaic shell yes it's like a plastic
shell and so you look at these these
news outlets they have no original
thought I have a conspiracy theory oh
let's hear it John they wanted Jon
Stewart to become an empty shell and he
wouldn't so he left really
what do you mean like they wanted him to
do the to do whatever those replacements
doing it I don't know I kind of I hear
you but I also kind of feel like George
Carlin and Jon Stewart were like
floodgates for the left yes and when you
know George Carlin fast all of a sudden
like the slime and grime MPC phases
started pouring in yeah I just imagine
like you know that scene in spider-man
where spider-man's got the webs and he's
holding the train he stopped it I was
like George Carlin he's like I want
George Carlin here to weigh in on this
so bad because he was a hippie dippie
lefty kind of dude yeah he wouldn't he
rejected all of this stuff yes and I
mean to an extent even Jon Stewart it
was awesome when Jon Stewart was talking
about the 9/11 Victims Fund yes and he
said like thank you Donald Trump you're
the only one who's actually fighting for
these people you had no problem saying
it and I'm like thank you like I I like
it's my schtick is basically like dude
Trump's got a bad attitude but he
deserves credit if he does something
right and the story you can hate the guy
you can despise the guy but if he's
helping 9/11 victims
thank you you know encourage the good
behavior and that's important to him - I
mean yeah Yorker yep yep and he's like
one of the few people was actually like
Jon Stewart's an awesome dude
yeah it's too bad though he retired and
he was like the last person holding back
the gates of all of this insane moral
authoritarianism that you started
flooding in and now the media like for
whatever reason Fox News like look at
this on the screen I got Fox News hiring
Donna Brazile it's you know you know
Donna Brazile is yeah the DNC right she
was she got a contract with Fox are they
just being objective right I don't
understand when that kind of leak that
everything happened with the agency I
think Fox News realized that the left or
whatever it is was kicking out its own
people yep and so they were like scoop
them up yeah and so they'll end up
sacrificing some more of their staunch
maybe like more evangelical or whatever
you know supporters or viewers but
they'll open up a tent to literally ten
million former Obama voters who switched
for Trump yeah because the media is just
pumping out trash like I was saying
before about the New York Times they
would rather lie about what's going out
the coronavirus which could literally
cause loss of life because they want to
smear a Republican
that's how insane it is like Tom cotton
said nothing unreasonable mm-hmm
now the Washington Post is that or is
that who published it or within the both
it was New York Times and The Washington
Post okay I always look at who owns
these things and I believe the
Washington Post is owned by Jeff Bezos
that's right yeah so I always wonder
about the bigger because they're gonna
say whatever their owner wants I mean
look at look at Bloomberg comm literally
saying we're not going to cover
Bloomberg if it's Jeff Bezos who runs
Amazon saying China's safe right I mean
yeah that that would make what deals
does Amazon have they're threatened by
bad press about are we gonna get Corona
and we're gonna get coronavirus if we
open up our sweaters remember that
Simpsons episode which one Homer orders
the orange juicer from China or whatever
or was from Japan I don't know and as
they're boxing it they got coughs into
it I don't
or opens it the germs flyness oh my god
I never saw that episode but they
predicted the future so many times it
doesn't surprise me but you're not gonna
get coronavirus from ordering something
like opening a box yeah I mean maybe I
don't know but that's that that's crazy
it's like I do this I have this test if
you if you go to my Instagram Instagram
datacom slash Tim cast I posted it
scroll down I do this thing where as
like a gag to my friends I'll put on Fox
News and they'll be talking about
something it's a lot of politics a lot
of the time but they mostly do talk
about politics or they do the feel-good
stories which which are no no but when
they were protests sweeping Iran uh-huh
Hong Kong wah Mexico mm-hmm
when there was an a big winter storm
coming they cover it
yeah and so I'm like I bet if I switch
to CNN right now Trump orange man orange
man all it is it's all orange man yeah
that's all they do I was at a skate park
yep and I was skating with a bunch of
like people of all ages but they're like
my age or younger yeah and there were
two kids who are like 17 mm-hmm and now
and we were just talking about general
cultural issues because skateboarders
tend to be like super libertarian oh
yeah but they're hippies so it's like
you know kind of like me like leave me
alone let me skate let me know my thing
as jordan peterson says don't bother
children when they're skateboarding yeah
but then i started talking about how
like you can't trust anything on TV and
then one k just goes dude CNN only talks
about Trump I started laughing and I'm
like yeah high-five buddy like you get
it yeah like what's up with that so if
you want if you want to watch something
and and what's crazy is like if you want
to watch something with legitimate
diversity of opinion you have to watch
Tucker Carlson of all people he's gonna
have anybody on there and he's gonna
talk to them and he's had an T fought on
his show yeah I remember yeah I turn on
I turn on CNN and Bryan Center has media
matters on and I'm like ah you're
enforcing your echo-chamber won't
claiming they're the media matters oh
where he covers all the typos the typos
the Trump typos he did a whole Media
Matters no no no that's Brian's right
yes that's the other one yes we think it
matters is the smear campaign
okay all right yes I mix them up but yes
he did um Trump's typos his typos he did
a whole segment on typos and he does
this thing where he like tries to
qualify
like qualify why it's okay he's doing it
he goes now I understand you might be
saying typos aren't really that big of a
deal but we're talking about the
president here it's like I get it you're
trying to diffuse the people who are
gonna we're gonna come after you because
you're doing a show about nonsense
ridiculous but yeah it's like we're in
this crazy time now I never thought I
would be at the point where I would turn
on Fox News for a Bernie Sanders Town
Hall which is more fair yeah and the
coverage he gets unlike MSNBC or
something wasn't it because they they
wouldn't do one for him or something oh
yeah Fox News was the only one who would
agree to do a town hall for him at a
certain point in the campaigning so
here's what I love when Trump comes out
and says they're cheatin Bernie yep it's
in my opinion first and foremost because
they are yes and they did it last time
and he doesn't care Trump doesn't care
he's a yeah he's pointing it out likely
but then you the media said why he was
doing it there Trott he's trying to
destabilize the Democrats or those like
so it's like yes that's the whole thing
because we have to vote blue no matter
who and Trump's trying to tear us apart
by saying that we're rigging this but
you guys know we aren't we wouldn't do
that to you but do you think Trump sits
there and like thinks like long and hard
about what he's gonna tweet or do you
think he just grabs his phone's like
exactly I mean as he's brilliant like
right pick one you can yeah he can't he
can't be both at the same time you know
he they're a mastermind or he's an idiot
which is it but if you think about it
from probably more of a trump supporter
perspective mm-hmm Trump just firing off
a tweet off-the-cuff isn't smart or
stupid
yes it seems giving his opinion it is
and so often they view him as actually
planning out his moves especially when
comes to Twitter to to like distract the
media mm-hmm but on the left they're
arguing he's really really dumb but then
also subverting the Democratic Party
with his support of Bernie Sanders like
that view is simultaneously the
mastermind a [ __ ] stupid criminal
mastermind yeah like what does it say
about them if this guy's a [ __ ] but
he's also the corrupt criminal genius
you think he is yep and he's winning
mm-hmm man I that sounds like really
awful things about you what they start
to do what what I see in circles that
they start to do it they stop looking at
Trump and start looking at his
supporters Frank so they'll take so
Charlie too yeah exactly so Trump isn't
Trump isn't a criminal mastermind his
supporters are idiots for believing it
and then it comes down to one of you
know the 10 standard talking points bad
words children in cages right you know
and just whatever it is and it'll come
down to his supporters his supporters
the supporters and they do do the same
thing with Bernie his supporters his
supporters his supporters to take to
take it off of them so they don't have
to argue whether or not it's an idiot or
super genius and it's because Hillary
Clinton like Pete Buddha jej Biden don't
have supporters they have like default
liberals sitting at home watching sports
or whatever and then they get a phone
call where it's like who you vote inform
like I don't know Biden I guess yeah and
they don't know anything about it they
don't watch it they don't pay attention
name familiarity yeah and so then when
you get actual supporters of anyone
who's actually a fan they express
themselves online all of a sudden you
have the smear campaign against Trump
against Bernie has I don't think totally
tulsi or actually yang got some of this
mm-hmm
early on they were claiming Andrew
Yang's supporters were far-right like
yeah is the weirdest thing oh we get
that for well I've gotten that for Tulsi
- yeah right right right that's actually
the thing that it's actually I mean I'm
in Massachusetts and I have a Facebook
page and not I don't have one for the
redhead libertarian just my personal one
never use it I just go on there
sometimes just to look around and lose
faith in the universe again but I I went
on and some it was right after the town
hall and somebody had said I don't know
who needs to hear this but Tulsi is a
far-right plant we need to stop putting
your faith in right because she did she
she ranked like sixth or seventh in the
New Hampshire because she put all of her
work into news she like moved there and
Wow
yeah she really did everything for New
Hampshire and she got like what like
almost 4% you have the vote I mean and
and that's with no coverage on CNN
that's with nothing but just
door-to-door the problem is that the
activists run the primaries yep and so
that's why you're seeing Bloomberg and
Warren come out but you know what the
end up getting welcomed going broke
because then they died in the polls they
lose their donations but they need those
cringy you know activists a vote form in
the primary
otherwise we're not gonna make it mm-hmm
but what's interesting too is I think
you have Budaj edge Klobuchar Biden
Bloomberg they're splitting the moderate
vote up bad mm-hmm
so conspiracy theory Bloomberg's friends
with Trump Bloomberg is dumping all this
money he's a Republican and then an
independent yeah he's gone all over the
board and he's flooding the Democratic
primary process destroying everything
about them Wow Nate silver said that
we're getting closer and closer to a
contested convention and one of the
reasons is that Bloomberg is disrupting
the whole process by skipping the first
primaries I had said that I said it's
gonna be a contested election because
Bernice Bernie's gonna have it until
when it becomes a contested election
according to the new rules for the
damaged super-delegates come in
super-delegates walk right in and take
it right away from Bernie again yep mark
my words heard it here helped I agree
I'm not the same thing yeah I just
responded to will Chamberlain put a bet
on Bloomberg for the nomination mm-hmm
cuz they're not gonna let Bernie take it
you know I agree I think Bernie is gonna
have just a little bit more super
delegate on regular delegates mhm but
then they're gonna say oh no it's
contested there's there's there's you
know not enough to determine and then
super Dallas cuz super-delegates will
step in yeah Bloomberg absolutely yeah
but so a lot of a lot of I saw a lot of
activists on the Left posting pictures
of Bloomberg and Trump together mmm
they're friends they're friends is that
something similar about Hillary and
Trump yeah but I'm like I'm not saying
it's true but if one conspiracy thought
it's a big club and you ain't in it that
Bloomberg is secretly flooding the
marking the the Democrats too so that no
one can win moderates get split up yeah
then maybe like maybe Bernie does take
it because they think Trump will
decimate him in the general thank you
check it out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we're live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and if you want to
catch the full recorded podcast which
doesn't appear in these clips make sure
you join by clicking the button down
below become a member and then go to the
community tab of this youtube channel
and you can see all of our full episodes
don't forget to like share and subscribe
if you want to get more clips like this
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all in the next show
you